[Musique]
mardi 9 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur tv78 voici les titres de
cette
[Musique]
édition et ce matin dans les Yvelines un
manteau blanc épais de 1 à 3 cm était
visible par endroit résultat des de
circulation sur la route et dans les
transports en commun qui ont impacté les
habitants la vigilance orange
neigeverglas est maintenue jusqu'à
demain matin dans le département il
s'exprime pour la première fois depuis
le début de la polémique le maire de
manilamo Bertrand ouon a profité de ses
vœux hier pour revenir sur les dernières
semaines de tension dans sa commune un
habitant s'est retrouvé menacé de mort
en voulant s'informer sur un projet de
lieu cultuel musulman Bertrand Ouillon
lui-même a été visé par des menaces
goldorac capitaine flamme ou encore
Albator C héros venu tout droit du Japon
on débarqué dans la vie des français
dans les années 70 et 80 l'espace richot
à Versailles leur consacre en ce moment
une exposition robot émergence d'une
culture japonaise vous dévoile une
collection de 300 pièces c'est ouvert
jusqu'au 25 février et puis l'invité du
78 en 2è partie d'édition tout au long
du mois de janvier les maires de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline viennent
présenter les grands projets de l'année
2024 dans leur commune ce soir Philippe
guigen sera avec nous il est le maire
des clés sousbois et avec moi comme hier
autour la Michel idoro bonsoir de la
rédaction tv78 vous allez nous présenter
le reste des actualités en bref
j'imagine qu'on y parle de neige
notamment oui évidemment on a tous été
émerveillés ce matin quand on a ouvert
les volets malheureusement sur la route
ça pas forcément été simple pour tout le
monde vous avez été surpris émerveillé
est-ce que surpris vous avez été en ah
oui totalement surpris oui oui bettoo
France nous avez pas averti spécialement
hier dans notre édition d'hier donc
forcément un peu surpris bon il y aura
d'autres informations aussi au menu de
ces actu actualité en bref ce sera dans
quelques minutes sur
tv78 et on en parle avec vous Michel un
épisode neéjeux a touché le département
la nuit dernière et aujourd'hui un
Morteau blanc de 1 à 3 cm à recouvert
les chaussées trînant de nombreux
bouchons sur les routes et galère pour
les automobilistes avec la fermeture
d'axe routiers ou quelques difficultés
dans les transports en commun retour sur
la journée avec Julien Leroi et Aurélie
lafeille une galère pour les usagers des
autoroutes à 12 et à 13 ce mardi 9
janvier des chutes de neige inattendues
ont entraîné la fermeture temporaire de
ces axes jusqu'en fin de matinée en
cause une couche de 1 à 3 cm de neige
créant quelques légers accidents à
10h196 km de bouchon étit comptabilisé
sur les routes franiliennes selon les
données trafic citadin des conditions de
circulation difficiles observé également
un peu partout dans le département les
autoroutes n'ont pas été salées
préventivement je je je porte pas de
jugement mais en tout cas il elle
n'avait pas été salé donc les autoroutes
étaient fermées ce matin pour permettre
le traitement et donc le trafic qui
s'écoule habituellement sur les
autoroutes s'est reporté sur les route
départementale ce qui a provoqué de
l'engorgement du côté de canttin en
iveline 12 salleuses desneéigeuses
étaient mobilisé pour assurer la
sécurité des usagers sur l'agglomération
un premier passage des machines a été
effectué vers 23h hier soir avant un
nouveau passage dans le courant de
l'après-midi une situation inattendue
c'est particulièrement difficile tout
simplement parce que meto France on n
pas eu d'information
que la neige allait tomber donc on a été
pris de cour fallait faire ça un peu en
urgence pour pouvoir déblayer les rues
concernant les transports en commun les
lignes L N et U ont subi des
perturbations à cause des mauvaises
conditions météorologiques des trains
mais aussi des bus ralentis dans la
matinée conséquence à l'université de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline les examens ont
été perturbés j'ai raté tous mes portiel
j'espère que je vais pouvoir attraper
mon portiel il y a mon bus qui a été
annulé du coup c'était un peu tendu pour
arriver il y a plein de monde qui avit
des problèmes de train notre partie elle
a commencé en retard et la moitié qui
est arrivé à 1 heure pas possible du
coup c'était compliqué ce matin le
préfet des Yvelines appelle les usagers
de la route à la plus grande prudence un
épisode que Météo France n'avait pas vu
venir plaçant le département en
vigilance orange neige verglas jusqu'à
demain
matin le point sur le reste des
actualités dans les
yvlines et on revient forcément sur cet
épisode neigeux puisque ce soir les
ivelines sont toujours en vigilance
orange neigeeverglet les autorités
appellent à la prudence oui Météo France
maintient la vigilance orange neige
verglas jusqu'à demain 6h du matin dans
un communiqué de presse la préfecture
des ivelines appelle à la plus grande
prudence sur les routes la vitesse est
limitée à 70 km/h sur les axes
principaux les dépassements sont
interdits pour les véhicules de plus de
7,5 tonnes vous pouvez vous renseigner
sur les conditions de circulation sur le
site internet m.citadin.f FR ou encore
privilégier les transports en commun
pour faciliter le passage des engins de
dégagement des routes il est également
demandé de stationner en dehors des voie
de circulation soyez également prudent
si vous rencontrez des fils électriques
tombés au sol autre information si vous
habitez l'une des communes de 50 an
Livine et que vous souhaitez être alerté
par SMS des interventions de celleuses
ou des chutes de neige à prévoir vous
pouvez vous abonner au portail espace
public service de Saint-Quentin en livin
et d'ailleurs on a reçu he la petite
puisque la prochain le prochain passage
des déneéigeuses est prévu pour ce soir
cette nuit même à 4h du matin vigilance
donc à maintenir les conditions
s'améliorent malgré la galère pour
certains aujourd'hui la la neige nous a
tout de même offert quelques belles
images oui Grégory àésiline on revêtu un
joli manteau blanc cette nuit nous
offront parfois de beaux paysages
enneigés je vous laisse contempler ces
quelques
images
[Musique]
bon on a le droit à ces images quasiment
une fois par an mais à chaque fois c'est
vrai qu'on on ne finit pas de s'en
émerveiller alorsux on en prend plein
les yeux effectivement on a un très beau
département aussi il faut le dire autre
actualité Michel vous allez nous parler
à présent des des tensions qui règnent
dans la commune de maniléamoau oui hier
soir Bertrand Houillon le maire de la
commune présenté ses vœux 2024 aux
habitants parmi les sujets abordés la
construction d'une mosquée qui avait
suscité la polémique en décembre dernier
pour rappel la mairie projetée de
permettre la construction d'un lieu de
culte musulman porté par l'association
des musulmans de manilé Hau le projet
avait suscité de nombreuses
interrogations chez les manquois l'un
d'entre eux ayant notamment été menacé
de mort sur les réseaux sociaux le maire
s'est exprimé à ce sujet au micro de
Julien Laura je condamnerai toujours
toutes les menaces d'où qu'elles
viennent et pour qui que ce soit j'ai
redit un appel à l'apaisement et à la
sérénité puisque c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne à manilé Hamo c'est du vivre
ensemble et queles que soient les
diversités dans lesqueles on est on
accepte tout le monde point final alors
c'est vrai que j'en ai pas parlé je suis
rester très silencieux toutes ces
dernières semaines ça fait 4 semaines
que je reçois des injures des mises en
cause de mon intégrité des diffamations
des messages aussi d'incitation à la
haine et à la violence et puis des
menaces mais là-dessus je le gère avec
la gendarmerie avec les services de la
préfecture avec la justice
essayera pour le moment le projet de
construction reste maintenu dans la
commune on terminees information du jour
Michel avec une bonne nouvelle bonne
nouvelle pour l'école 2600 oui vous le
savez grégoryi la cybersécurité
représente un grand enjeu pour le 21e
siècle comment protéger nos ordinateurs
nos téléphones ou tout système
électronique contre des attaques
malveillantes l'école 2600 située à
montinil bretonu travaille ardemment
elle a d'ailleurs été nommée meilleure
école de France en cyber sécurité on
écoute la réaction du directeur général
adjoint on a été reconnu meilleure école
cyber de France lors de la cybern 2023
par la République Haïti donc c'est un
prix qui a été quand même décerné par un
jury de 800
professionnels à l'issue de cette
formation d'excellence l'objectif pour
nous c'est que sur le marché de l'emploi
nos étudiants mais pas queux tout
individu toute entreprise qui cherche à
pousser ses salariés vers l'excellence
en matière de la cyber puisse le faire
au travers de notre plateforme de
formation continue d'ici 2030 les école
2600 veut former 10000 personnes sur
trois disciplines principales la
cybersécurité la sécurité défensive
offensive et la gouvernance une ambition
primordiale quand on sait que la pénurie
de compétence en terme de Cyb sécurité
persiste dans le monde merci Michel pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi prês de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les evvelin
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news l'actualité de janvier c'est
aussi si ce défi lancé jusqu'à la fin du
mois il a plusieurs avantages économiser
de l'argent mieux dormir et surtout être
en meilleure santé le Dr januarier nous
invite à stopper notre consommation
d'alcool jusqu'à la fin du mois voici
quelques conseils pour tenter de relever
ce challenge avec l'association La Croix
Bleue de Versailles elle accompagne les
personnes souffrant
[Musique]
d'alcoolisme d'abord c'est un défi en
fait ça commence comme ça c'est une une
expérience de vie qu'on peut partager et
qui consiste à faire une pause avec
toute consommation alcoolique pendant
environ un
mois je vous conseille d'essayer de
faire ça en groupe c'est plus sympa vous
pouvez le faire en famille vous pouvez
le faire avec des amis vous pouvez aussi
le faire directement via des réseaux
sociaux il y a des groupes qui se créent
pour ça parce que c'est plus sympa et
c'est plus motivant ça c'est la première
chose c'est pas faire tout seul parce
que c'est plus fun la deuxième c'est
c'est d'anticiper sa consommation en
fait pour sortir des habitudes sortir
des automatismes quand vous alleer un
afterw avec des collègues souvent vous
arrivez vous assayez vous dites
qu'est-ce qu'on vous propose une bière
vous réfléchissez même pas à ce que vous
voulez consommer et là c'est ce qui est
bien dans ce défi justement c'est que
vous allez revenir en pleine conscience
et décider ce que vous allez
consommer les gens se rendent pas compte
mais en à peine un mois les gens la
plupart des gens qui qui qui ont arrêté
le disent ils ils ont un meilleur
comportement de sommeil c'est il dorment
beaucoup mieux par impact quand on dort
mieux on est une meilleure humeur on a
une meilleure con concentration on a
beaucoup de choses comme ça la deuxième
le deuxième gros avantage sans ça
s'explique vraiment parce que les gens
le disent c'est une sensation d'aller
mieux physiologiquement ça s'explique
parce que pas de consommation d'alcool
moins de
cholestérol moins de sucre dans le sang
baisse de la pression sanguine bref
forcément tout ça ça va mieux on sont
mieux en forme on peut faaire du sport
plus facilement et puis le troisième
petit avantage comme je vous ai dit
surtout après les fêtes pas de
consommation d'alcool
[Musique]
économie propos recueilli par Aurélie
lafeille allez on ouvre tout de suite
une page culture dans le
[Musique]
78 si vous êtes amateur de la culture
japonaise cette exposition est faite
pour vous jusqu'au 25 février près de
300 robots japonais et des années 70 à
80 sont visibles à l'espaceera de
Versailles l'occasion de replonger dans
les temps dans le temps et de retrouver
son âme d'enfant avec quelques
classiques Clara de fruit Gabri Gontier
et patrickc de
[Musique]
dixmud goldorac astoy capitaine flamme
en passant par Albator c'est la plus
grande collection française de robots
japonais des années 70 80 celui qui en
est à l'origine c'est lui Baptiste
cillot pendant 25 ans il a collectionné
près de 3 robot japonais mais aussi leur
boîte d'origine pour la première fois il
expose toutes ses pièces à l'espace
richau de versaill jusqu'au 25 février
2024 nous on a on a découvert la cette
cette culture japonaise du manga et de
l'animé avec goldorac encore une fois
cette culture qui était tellement loin
de la nôtre avec ses ces robots géants
pilotés par par des êtres humains des
jeunes gens c'est la première fois que
les enfants se sentaient aussi touché
par un dessin animé première fois avec
ses couleurs vives c'est c'est c'est
c'est héros surdimensionné encore une
fois qui échappait totalement à notre
imaginaire et en fait ils ont compris
qu'ils allaient pouvoir par leur culture
influencer
énormément une culture européenne et
c'est à partir de là qui'est né le soft
power japonais ces robots ne sont plus
de simples jouets ils sont devenus de
véritables produits marketing témoignant
l'influence culturelle du Japon à
l'international c'est la première fois
qu'en France en fait on avait des
dessins animé avec autant de produits
dérivés autour donc Goldor qui était
dans sa souscoupe il était sur des mugs
sur dans des autocollant sur des cartes
Panini des t-shirts en fait il y avait
un marchandising gigantesque des vinyes
tout ça et c'est la première fois
nous français on découvrait ça si
l'exposition met notamment l'accent sur
l'iconique goldorac les visiteurs
pourront aussi découvrir d'autres pièces
uniques fabriqué par des manufactures
japonaises plus confidentielles certains
robots n'ont jamais été montrés en
France dans son merveilleux robot de
lumière et d'acier
une nouveauté à présent dans le 78
chaque mardi maxense de la croué jeune
ivelinois passionné d'histoire viendra
vous conter quelques anecdotes
historiques sur le département pour ce
premier numéro Maxence lève le voile sur
un mystère d'où vient le nom des
evvelines voici la réponse pour ce
premier podcast sur les faits
historiques des evvelines quoi de mieux
que de commencer par l'origine du
département et de son
appellation le départ des ivin tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui a vu le jour en 1964 le
10 juillet une nouvelle loi promulgue la
réorganisation de la région parisienne
cette loi supprime les départements scè
et sainewaise pour donner naissance au
Département de Paris des hautes scèes de
la Scine Saint-Denis et des Yvelines
mais de nombreux débats ont eu lieu
autour du nom choisi pour le nouveau
département Charles de Gaulle alors
président de la République souhaite
l'appeler Versailles sa volonté
représenter le département sous un nom
qui rayonne à l'international mais 4 ans
plus tard en 1968 le poète versaillis
Jeant d'Espère propose de donner le nom
d'iveline au département cela fait
référence au pays d'iveline sans s issu
d'une ancienne forêt de la haute Vallet
de Chevreuse dont Rambouillet est le
dernier vestige Eveline vient du latin
syva Aquilina littéralement forêt gorgée
d'eau en effet plusieurs rivières
avaient pour source cette forêt mais
alors d'où vient le S à la fin des
Yvelines cette précision s'explique par
l'intermédiaire de Jeant d'Esper qui
aurait dit avec un S Eveline ça faisait
plus riche avant l'invité du 78 coup
d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain et on parle bien iici de
prévision on n'est pas à l'abri comme ce
matin d'avoir un épisode enneigé une
surprise enneigé comme ce matin dans le
département alors selon Météo France pas
de neige prévu ce mercredi mais des
conditions nuageuses et des températures
négatives le matin il fera -1°gr à
Mantel jolie et Rambouillet - 2 degr à
Versailles et jusqu'à - 3°gr à Houdan
l'après-midi le mercure repasse dans le
positif dans le nord des Yvelines 1 degr
à montelajolie la température sera de
0°gr à Versailles et Houdan et c'est
dans le sud iveline qu'il fera le plus
froid avec moins 2 degr prévu dans le
secteur de Rambouillet et ce mercredi 10
janvier nous fêterons les Guillaumes
tout de suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et c'est Philippe guigen qui est avec
moi bonsoir bonsoir maire des clés
sousbois également conseil communautaire
de 50 ans evveline délégué à
l'Enseignement supérieur et au marché
publics bonne année à vous déjà et au à
tous les cléiens qui nous regardent une
première question qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de 2023 on sait que c'est une
année qui a été marquée par de
nombreuses crises et inflation une
inflation galopante vous aviez
d'ailleurs alerté le président de la
République sur les difficultés
grandissantes pour les communes qui ont
de moins en moins de ressources
effectivement il y a eu des événements
positifs et des événements négatifs pour
les évacuer très rapidement les
événements négatifs ce sont bah les les
les émeutes du du mois de juin et je
peux me féliciter que que dans ma
commune nous avons été relativement
épargnés et je suis totalement solidaire
avec les maires et notamment ceux de de
notre agglomération qui ont subi de de
très très gros préjudices euh des
événements euh moins moins positif
également ce sont l'inflation vous
l'avez dit qui touche l'ensemble des
ménages et notamment
l'écléienne et l'écléiens et puis euh
j'ai alerté effectivement dans cet ordre
d'esprit euh le président de la
République de manière à ce que des
communes comme la nôre les clés
sous-bois nous ne subissions pas de
façon systématique des pertes
d'autonomie financière comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui et donc c'est à ce titre
que j'ai demandé j'ai souhaité qu'il y
ait et j'ai alerté qu'il y ait une
réforme très importante sur les
dotations pour des communes comme la
nôtre et comment vous abordez 2024
est-ce que malgré ce contexte vous allez
pouvoir maintenir un certain niveau
d'investissement au alors bien entendu
nous allons pouvoir maintenir un certain
niveau d'investissement parce que nous
avions anticipé avec avec mon équipe
toutes les toutes les difficultés depuis
un certain nombre un certain nombre
d'années l'investissement est un moteur
essentiel dans dans dans les communes de
même qu'au niveau qu'au niveau de de
l'État et de très nombreux projets ont
pu être initiés en 2023 sur la commune
des Clais et vont se poursuivre en 2024
et après il y a eu des projets notamment
la la police fusionnée avec la la
commune de de plaisir ça peut aussi
passer par ce type de solution
mutualiser des moyens quand quand c'est
nécessaire tout à fait l'objectif est
est de mutualiser donc pour réduire les
coûts et pour être plus efficace et nous
avons avec ma collègue Joséphine colzman
berger maire de plaisir décidé de
mutualiser les les les polices de
manière à avoir une police de proximité
efficace qui est une attente importante
de l'ensemble de notre population donc
maintien des investissements est-ce que
vous allez toucher un levier qui est
celui des de l'imposition locale est-ce
que vous allez augmenter en en 2024
l'imposition locale en 2024 je je ne
l'augmenterai pas après 13 ans j'ai été
contraint en 2000 en 2023 cont tenu de
ce que j'ai expliqué au préalable mais
tous les investissements à venir sont
sont sont financés et j'espère qu'ils
iront sans problème à leur terme al
beaucoup de choses positives forcément
2024 c'est une année olympique avec les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 une partie
des épreuves une grande partie même va
se dérouler sur ce territoire
cinquantinois l'éclés sous-bois a le
label terre de jeu et aussi centre de
préparation pour ces Go vous allez
proposer à la population des des
événements qui sont liés au J et
notamment les établissements scolaires
qui vont faire leur propre GI il y aura
une cérémonie d'ouverture de clôture ça
se déroulera en juin tout à fait nous
avons nous avons souhaité associer un
maximum d'acteurs à cette à cette
période olympique et paralympique et les
acteurs ce seront aussi bien les
associations sportives mais aussi les
associations culturell et également les
écoles avec une semaine totalement
dédiée avec une cérémonie d'ouverture
des épreuves une cérémonie de clôture
cérémonie de clôture qui normalement
devrait se se traduire par la venue du
du groupe versaillais back to 80 en même
temps que la fête de la musique donc il
y aura un côté nostalgique au moment de
un côté nostalgique festif et et aussi
sportif bien entendu tournant bien sûr
vers l'avenir alors le grand projet qui
va voir le jour en 2024 au cl sbis c'est
cette maison de santé PL professionnel
qui va voir le jour en lieu et place de
l'ancien bâtiment de la sécurité sociale
avenue Jules Ferry on imagine un
équipement attendu par les habitants
alors c'est l'un des grands projets mais
effectivement c'est peut-être le projet
pH pour l'année l'année prochaine il est
attendu par par beaucoup de de de la
population parce que beaucoup de
communes sont face à des déserts
médicaux c'est pas tout à fait le cas au
clésbois mais il est très important de
d'anticiper pour avoir des des des
outils mis à disposition de l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé d'ailleurs à
ce titre je remercie tout le groupe des
professionnels de santé qui se sont
associés avec moi dès l'initiative de ce
de ce projet en 2020 et en 2021 enfin
grâce aux financeurs comme le
département comme l'agglomération comme
la région et aussi un très très gros
autofinancement de la commune nous
devrions aboutir à un projet attendu par
l'ensemble d'éclétienes éclétiens donc
il va avoir donc le jour on disait sur
cette année 2024 il y a aussi un effort
qui continue sur les écoles alors il y a
la fin des travaux de l'école Jean jores
qui donc est programmé pour cette année
il y a aussi l'école Henri pierou qui va
bénéficier de travaux d'isolation alors
c'est l'école enri prou oui nous nous
allons achever euh 3 ans de travaux sur
euh sur l'école sur l'école jeanoress à
la fin à la fin de de l'année de l'année
scolaire de travaux nous avons une
réflexion totale de l'ensemble de cette
école puisqueque nous allons être proche
de 4 millions d'euros une réflex une
réflexion totale là nous en sommes dans
dans dans la phase de des travaux
d'isolation et d'ailleurs à ce titre
nous envisageons même de de de faire de
trouver des des process pour avoir le
moins de nuisance possible vis-à-vis des
des enseignements pendant les derniers
travaux de de finition et l'école en r
prou ça une deuxième école sur la
laquelle nous allons attaquer un
programme de rénovation et notamment sur
tout ce qui est énergétique à
l'extérieur avec les changements de
fenêtres à titre d'exemple prou il y a
un i entre qui s'était glissé
effectivement dans dans cette école donc
qui va bénéficier de travaux d'isolation
les les autres grands projets vous vous
les évoquz quels sont-ils les les autres
grands projets l'année prochaine nous
avons des des nous allons poursuivre nos
investissements qui sont des des
investissements récurent nous
allons créer autour de la autour de de
la mairie et de l'espace Noiré un
nouveau parking paysagé de près de 50
places qui est aussi qui est aussi
attendu nous allons travailler avec les
jeunes pour créer un espace multisport
près du du gymnaseour Bourneton
Bourneton et voilà deux deux projets
importants pour l'année pour pour
l'année prochaine mais nous nous allons
maintenir un niveau d'investissement
important au niveau de la commune parce
que malgré les difficultés de
fonctionnement auxquels des communes
comme la nôtre sont sont contraints ben
nous avons anti iciper sur ces sur ces
investissements sur ces deux projets
notamment ce ce parking ça va faciliter
la vie des habitants autour de de cet
espace oui ça va faciliter la
effectivement les laavenue pour pour cet
espace puisque aujourd'hui il n'y avait
qu'un seul qu'un seul parking devant la
mairie là il y aura il y aura 50 places
supplémentaires en plus nous allons
réaliser une allée de de de jonction
entre le vieux centrebourg et l'espace
de l'amirie qui va être totalement
totalement rénové donc vous le disiez
aussi un plateau multisport à proximité
du gymnase Bourneton on évoquait aussi
des événements festifs on a parlé de cet
événement back to 80 il y aura aussi une
date à reenir le 8 mai puisqu'il y aura
aussi euh la célébration des 60 ans du
jumelage alors franco-allemand et aussi
franco-portugais au clé sousbis alors 60
ans pour les franco-allemands pas 60 ans
pour pour les franco-porticulier mais
effectivement il y a il y a un jumelage
qui qui dure depuis depuis près de 60
ans qui avait été initié à suite au au
aux accords entre le général de Gaulle
et puis et adenhauer et tout de suite la
la ville d'éclais sous bois a pris le a
pris le relais et c'est une enfin c'est
un jumelage qui qui vit qui vit très
très bien nous avons fêté les 50 ans il
y a 10 ans il y aura il y aura les 60
ans il y aura donc une délégation
importante qui va venir au CLA sous-bois
et j'ai aussi souhaité associer
redémarrer le notre notre jumelage
franco-portugais avec une délégation qui
sera beaucoup beaucoup plus restreinte
mais il est important dans ces périodes
que l'ensemble de nos amis européens soi
associés voilà pour les grands temps
forts à venir de de la commune d'éclés
sousbois pour terminer fen on pose la
même question à tous nos invités tous
les meres 50 ans viennent ici sur ce
plateau pour le le mois de janvier on
vous donne une carte blanche là vous
avez une minute pour aborder un sujet
libre que vous choisirez bah le le sujet
libre même si ça peut être un cliché
c'est d'espérer que Ben le monde
retrouve une certaine sérénité une
certaine paix et de manière à ce que
chacun puisse avoir une une année de
bonheur de joie ça c'est sur de façon de
façon générale et et au niveau de nos de
notre commune d'cla ben j'espère que
l'ensemble de nos projets et je n'en
doute pas seront pourront être menés
menés à terme dans de très très bonnes
conditions ce qui me permet de de
remercier ben toutes les équipes
municipales mon équipe qui travaille une
équipe soudé ainsi que l'ensemble des
personnels des personnels communaux
parce que il est important que l'on
apporte à notre population un service
public de proximité de qualité et c'est
aussi pour ça pour éviter cette
dégradation que j'ai alerter alertter
sur les difficultés de financement pour
des communes comme la mienne voilà donc
une année de paisibilité merci d'avoir
été avec nous Philippe guigen maire de
la commune des claés sous-bois bonne
année une nouvelle fois encore à vous au
cléciennes et aux cléciens qui nous
regardent je précise juste que la
cérémonie des vœux au clés sous-bois est
prévue pour le mardi 23 janvier merci
encore d'avoir été avec nous c'est la
fin de ce 78 merci de votre fidélité
vous retrouverez demain Mathilde Francou
à la présentation d'une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78